only to believe maybe the jfk is coming
back to life i have no [ __ ] clue why
they chose that i mean anytime if if
anyone remembers in the 1990s when jfk
jr would actually do press conferences
for his liberal rag because he's a
liberal who owned a liberal magazine
he was a [ __ ] democrat not only that
he was a goddamn liberal
you hate liberals you hate them you
think they suck blood out of kids and
stuff he would be one of the blood
sucking george soros cabal you stupid
[ __ ]
anyways
when he would actually do a press
conference for his magazine he would do
it in new york city
like that's where he would have he
wouldn't go to dallas he would have it
in new york i mean that's be my
assumption i mean if jfk jr is still
alive that's what i assume he would do
that would be his natural instinct
anyways
but the craziest part
to me about this this because i think
this is actually some progress in other
words in real life progress because a
lot of this q and on stuff lives online
and these people live vicariously
through this q anon story and this q
anon storyline like wrestling
online right it's not it's not real life
right you get me it's not real life
they're participating with the storyline
virtually
and it's like reality tv on their cell
phone
right
well this is real life when they go down
there and they fly to dallas and they
all stand there in daly plaza waiting
for jfk junior to show up
and jfk junior does not show up or jfk
or bobby ken or any kennedy for that
matter they just they don't show up
and when that goes by they're like oh
[ __ ]
so then they gotta you know they gotta
move the goalpost of course so they move
it to some rolling stone concerts or
some [ __ ]
i guess that's maybe what some of these
people were there for was a rolling
stone concert i don't know if there's
like a huge q a on following for the
rolling stones or something but if there
really is apparently
apparently the rolling stones were
walking around dallas just out in the
open no one would bother him because
everyone was down there gawking at the
queuing honors
the the [ __ ] crazy zoo down on down
the flat daily plaza holy [ __ ]